to be successful today how we manage
Networks not how we manage our direct
reports how we work in networks is how
we create disproportionate change in the
world if you're a chief marketing
officer it's not just about what your
marketing does it's your partnership
with the sales organization and the and
the product organization you can be the
CMO the head of sales the head of
product all of those jobs are the chief
growth officer and it's all about
creating a partnership among those
critical individuals that's success it's
about the team I think we've over
indexed on leadership and we've under
indexed on teamship and that's been my
passion
um for the last 20 years
thank you
[Music]
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast number one New York Times
best-selling author I think multiple
times one of the world's greatest
authorities on helping both people and
organizations succeed Keith farazi
welcome Keith
Andrew this is going to be a lot of fun
I'm looking forward to it me too brother
so what most people might know you for
is you wrote this number one New York
Times best-selling book called Never Eat
Alone that kind of set the world a fire
it became uh you know this frankly it
was like a business book A
self-development book
um and I have to say it's an inspired
title because it really makes you think
it's like huh I really do eat a load a
lot it might be on missing opportunities
so what what led up to to that uh that
book well I don't know how far in the
rabbit hole you want to go by asking
that question but I'll I'll start to
peel back the onion and you tell me
please stop the the simple story was
that
um I had a disproportionately
um
incredibly successful young career
I was the chief marketing officer of
Deloitte before I was 30. crazy I was
Chief marketing officer at all of
Starwood Hotels and Resorts and head of
sales uh in my early 30s and um as a
result somebody came to me and said uh
you you know we'd like to write an
article about you and and I said well
let me think about it and the question
was
what precipitated your success and I and
this is a piece of advice for any of
your listeners
um I paused instead of just blurting out
because it was supposed to be one of
these wraparound pieces that 20 people
were going to be interviewed Etc but I
but I said let me get back to you
tomorrow let me do the work and
overnight I came back with what what I
what I thought were my 10 secrets of
success
and I handed it to him well he went back
to his editor and he said we've got
something here let's just write the
piece on this guy and it ended up being
a major feature in ink magazine which
was one of their runaway best-selling
um uh pieces and it was called 10
secrets of a master networker I hated
the title
I did not I was a I was a thought leader
a businessman I was a lot of things I
was a philanthropist I was I was like I
cared about changing the world what the
I I was not like the networking guy
and I was so disgusted by the by the
article that I hired the author the
writer from from Inc magazine and I said
I'm gonna punish you you're gonna work
with me and we're gonna tell the full
story about how it's not about
networking but it's about true authentic
relationships I said we're going to
write a book so we ended up writing the
bigger story which ultimately became a
global bestseller now
the the thing that I was saying in terms
of it's a it's an interesting question
you did this in addition to your day job
as CMO of Starwood no I had left
Starwood by then and I was working for
Michael Milken
um I was the CEO I've always wanted to
run something
and so I realized back in the day you
couldn't go from CEO from CMO and I
needed to go into something smaller so
Michael Milken gave me one of his
portfolio companies to be CEO of I moved
to Los Angeles and I was running a
computer games company at the time uh
for Mike
and yes I did do it while that was
happening but I had an extraordinary
partner my co-writer uh was just
extraordinary and uh it was a it was a
it was a beautiful process and I've
written many books since probably one of
these this was probably one of the
easiest books I I've written it's
interesting when you write your first
book you know you've got the content of
30 years of getting prepared for that
first book and then when it's successful
the publisher wants your next book in a
year so you've got to scramble to to
find the content for that second book
okay so this book takes off in a way
that's completely probably like you know
like no one could have predicted it
unforeseen shall we say I mean even if
you were a competent guy you're not
gonna be like this is going to become a
global bestseller at the rest of it
um so does that end up taking over your
life for a particular period because I
know when that happens
um the Press wants a hold of you all the
time uh conferences among you all the
time
is that your story
I can share my story if you want I mean
it's good fun because like I I wrote my
my first book and the world did not like
you know notice which by the way I think
is a much more adorable set of
experiences I mean you've had like uh no
not with your book but with your
presidency run it was inspiring I just
want to let you know that as an outsider
who you know wasn't a Part of Your Inner
Circle you deeply inspired me with your
your your insights your words your
passion your Pursuit and uh I was
definitely rooting for your mission in
in the world so it's an honor to be here
um well thank you Keith
I'll tell you what what happens at a
time like that is is interesting and
this is another small bit of advice for
those watching I really did resent
being the networking guy in fact the
cover of the of the book
I I forced them to have up on the cover
relationships that power your success I
forget what the original tagline was but
they wanted it to be
you know something about networking tips
of a master networker exactly
um and but what I missed I really missed
an opportunity Andrew and I reflect upon
this with humility that when you have
momentum in life grab it
and the power of of prestige the power
of being in the spotlight and having a
Podium is something that one shouldn't
look askance to I mean it's something
that is very powerful and it's a it's a
gift it's a blessing and it should be
relished even at the small level of
inside of a company I mean there are
there are people that I know you know
young people who have had a lot of
success in their companies and their
companies love them and and they are but
they're successful in an area that maybe
someday they want to be in a different
area and they shun that success
and they're looking for for something
that is other than what they're
currently have momentum around and the
powerful thing about capturing momentum
is you know you may never have it again
at that level
and and what I've always found is that
having success under your belt can
always be pivoted to other types of
success
but running away from momentum into
other things that you may be interested
in or dalliances Etc these things can
actually really uh be a missed
opportunity for a lifetime so the one
thing I think about when I think about
Never Eat Alone
was you know that book came out and this
was pre-podcast days this was
pre-everything and what I was I was a
CEO and I had just we had just exited
the company
um and I had started frazzi Greenlight
and I was going to be focused on thought
leadership research and coaching
executive teams I wanted to coach the
most powerful teams in the world the
most powerful corporate teams in the
world I wanted to coach you know the the
cabinet of the United States I wanted to
coach
if if I were president you would be the
cabinet's coach but continue well we can
make we maybe we can take another run at
it maybe we could take it was very
interesting there were years ago where I
was actually having active dialogues
with um with Hillary Clinton about just
that and um but and so as a result I was
really afraid of being the networking
guy and I didn't capitalize on it I
didn't do the podcast I didn't do the
things like other friends of mine who
were at the same level as I was at the
time like Tim Ferriss he's like I want
to see this podcasting thing over here
um and you know the the all my only
advice to everybody look I've had an
extraordinary career and I've gone on to
create some extraordinary Works my books
are focused on leadership and teams you
know we coach some of the most
prestigious teams in the world I write
for every magazine possible I am so
blessed in my career but I do look back
and say what power could I have had in
my career in my in my platform
had I not run away from the momentum
that I had as I did at the time uh yeah
I'm sure you were bombarded with
requests and you're just like well I
can't speak at all these conferences
what's going on it was also the topic I
wanted to be focused on teams in
leadership not just networking and it's
funny because you you wake up 20 years
from then and Leadership is about
networking that's why I wrote the book
leading without Authority leading
without Authority teaches us that to be
successful today how we manage Networks
not how we manage our direct reports how
we work in networks is how we create
disproportionate change in the world if
you're a chief marketing officer it's
not just about what your marketing does
it's your partnership with the sales
organization and the and the product
organization I was speaking to a woman
yesterday who's getting back into the
workforce she was a CMO she went did an
entrepreneurial gig and it failed now
she's getting back into the workforce
and you know and I and she's and I and
I'm trying to explain to her the biggest
thing you need to convince a CEO as a
CMO is that you're going to partner like
hell with your head of sales and drive
revenue and outcomes not that you're a
great brand person
you need to talk about the partnership
of transforming the growth of a business
and being the chief growth officer you
could be the CEO I'm sorry you could be
the CMO the head of sales the head of
product all of those jobs are the chief
growth officer and it's all about
creating a partnership among those
critical individuals that's success it's
about the team I think we've over
indexed on leadership and we've under
indexed on teamship and that's been my
passion
um for the last 20 years
foreign
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
yeah you talk about co-elevating
um and and finding ways that everyone
wins which I think is by the way the
secret to building uh quality network is
that you're just trying to help other
people succeed a lot of the time and
sometimes the benefits to yourself are
completely unclear
that's the one thing I'm happy that
Never Eat Alone did is it did pivot this
understanding that building your network
is not about getting a lot out of other
people it's actually investing in people
and deepening authentic relationships
and if you live your life
saying being purposeful number one
there's nothing wrong with saying what
do I want to be in life and who are the
people I need to get to know to be there
that's perfectly acceptable A lot of
people get sketchy when they say well
building purposeful relationships is
fake no building fake relationships is
fake building authentic relationships
purposefully is strategic
and if you want to be whatever you want
to be in life look at the pathway of
people that will help you get there and
then go out there and authentically
build generous relationships in being of
service to those individuals that's
really the key the golden key to
unlocking a lot of success I grew up
very poor my old man was an unemployed
steel worker in Pittsburgh
um during the 70s and my nepotism had to
be created you know that's a that's a
beautiful expression and the way you
know nepotism is nothing more than
somebody who loves you who's going to
give you a leg up in the world and then
if that's true then make sure that the
people who you love and love you are
individuals who can open doors and and
share deal flow and find Opportunities
and teach you things this is what this
is what nepotism is all about but you
can create it for yourself
yeah there's some people that run away
from the relationships they might be
able to bring to the table and and
that's a mistake as well it's like look
if you've got relationships use them
there's no shame in that you know that's
a young person I hear this all the time
uh I don't ask my father for whatever I
don't want to you know I don't want to
ask my Uncle for whatever I I just I get
so frustrated and angry with young
people who say things like that I only
wish you know my father only wished he
could have given that to me and I only
wished my father could have given that
to me I believe that the greatest sin is
being put on this planet and not making
the biggest Ripple impact of not making
the biggest footprint that you possibly
can so our job in this world is to make
an impact in the world while we're here
now you can Define that if you mean that
with your family God bless you if you
mean that with whatever you can Define
how you want to Define impact for me
it's through the workforce I want to
um I want to make people's lives
different and better some similar to a
very good friend of mine Andrew I don't
know I think you met along the way my
dear friend Tony uh sure yeah so when
Tony died he was one of the greatest
influencers on my life in terms of
understanding humans in the workplace
when Tony died I created the Tony Shea
award and if any of your listeners out
there consider yourselves radical
innovators like Tony around human
capital go to the Tony shayaward.com and
apply for the award
um you know for me
my ability to make an impact in the
workplace uh you know it's like that's
when I was a kid I wanted to be a
minister and then I wanted to be
president I get to do all of that right
now just to be helpful in people's lives
but I got people five days a week in the
workplace yeah I'm I'm the son of
immigrants
um and so my parents did a lot for me in
terms of uh you know education uh hard
work that sort of thing
um but I agree you just use whatever
you've got you know if you've got it use
it as long as you're doing something
positive uh and one of the big mistakes
people make is they they think uh they
reverse this relationship they think you
do things because you know people and
what I say is you know people because
you do things like I I've built all of
these relationships because I was trying
to do something that other people had an
interest in or wanted to help with and
some of the relationships are lifelong
you know it because they're so uh pure
uh you know like like you both care
deeply about this thing and you both
worked hard on it I've got relationships
that you know at different times in my
life I wanted to achieve different
things when I was an entrepreneur I was
thinking I wanted to be a venture-backed
CEO for the rest of my life and we did a
small one
um and then we exited and that's when I
started frazi green light but I got to
know an entire group of individuals in
the Venture Capital Community other
entrepreneurs Etc and what's interesting
about that is even though that's not my
world anymore now I know some of the
most powerful Venture capitalists and
unicorn CEOs Etc who are incredibly
co-creative with me
um you know I find that every Twist and
Turn even as a young man when I was
wanting to run for president United
States I would have done it I highly
recommend it Keith not too late not too
late at 56 we'll see
um but you know what it's actually
interesting and the reason I I mean I I
was grooming my life to be president I
went to Yale and I ran for City Council
in New New Haven I moved to a district
where I could run for Congress that I
think I could win
um and it was just about that time right
out of University that I started to
realize that I was gay
and back in the
um back in the 80s that would not fly
yeah
and run for president United States or
even Congress there wasn't a Barney
Frank there wasn't anybody who was
openly gay there wasn't even a I mean at
that point in time Liberace claimed to
be straight so there was literally
nobody out there that was willing to
come forward Oscar Wilde but look what
that got him
um and for for me that pivot what was
interesting was that the pivot to say
okay well I'm not going to be able to be
president of the United States but
perhaps uh the same people who supported
me on the way here
could help me pivot and I was like under
debt from school Etc I'm going to go to
Harvard Business School but I couldn't
afford it and so the same individuals
that were ready to support me for
Congress
bought into my mission that I was going
to change the world through business and
gave me loans to go to Harvard Business
School that's incredible
yeah and you you talked about Tony Shea
Tony Shea uh the hero and role model to
so many entrepreneurs so many people uh
in
the Asian American Community for sure
and he and I shared time together I met
his family which which made uh his
passing all the more heartbreaking so
congratulations to you for uh
inaugurating an award in his memory I'm
sure he'd be honored and proud
this is um
this is the Tony Shea award
uh it's very suiting or fitting he only
wore one black Asic shoe it's the only
thing that he ever wore because he was
such a minimalist he taught me how to
only wear black t-shirts to decrease
choice in your mind when you get up in
the morning to stay focused but you know
what we say is we now have thousands of
people applying for this award nobody
can fill Tony's shoes but thousands
coming in his path who are equally
radically innovating in human capital
collectively might be able to so we're
really excited about what we're doing
with the Tony yeah congratulations
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
having a good mattress has always struck
me as one of the best investments you
can make because you spend a lot of time
on that mattress and having a healthy
night's sleep gives you energy for the
day keeps you healthy makes you capable
of doing all the things you want to do
why would you sleep on a mattress that's
made for someone other than you
especially in 2023 with Helix sleep you
can take a personalized quiz get one of
their 14 unique mattresses sent right to
your door have a hundred night trial and
a 10 plus year warranty yeah they have
that much confidence in their products
in part because they're manufactured
right here in the USA and it's the
number one mattress picked by GQ in
Wired Magazine Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
[Music]
one of the people that you and I have in
common is a young man named Jack Liang
who
um is this young up-and-coming uh
entrepreneur uh how did you get
connected to Jack and how the heck do
you choose among frankly the
um gajillion young people who I'm sure
would would love to
um have any kind of relationship with
you maybe I'll I'll spin back a little
bit so
um I have uh I have six boys
um and I'll describe what I mean by that
um so when my former partner and I were
thinking about children we had to ask
ourselves do we go the surrogacy route
um which was a possibility but I was
leaning toward there must be so many
amazing kids out there who don't have
parents and need homes why would we
bring another child into the world when
we could find somebody in need so I
started working with a group out of Los
Angeles called kid safe which did a
matching program for foster care where
instead of just being a foster parent
and they throw kids into your house you
know which maybe not want to be there
they may not be a match they provided a
matching program where you could become
a Big Brother Big Sister
uh and then over time bring that child
into your home if the if the click
worked and they wow they wanted to bring
that child in your home as a foster
parent and then adopt and through that
we had
um two two boys
um very very difficult
um backgrounds we got them at 12 and 16
into our lives
and
um I can go through lots of information
about foster care and what I learned
about it and we took that program then I
went and worked with governor governor
Hickenlooper who had become a good
friend and was very Progressive I
brought to Senator Dick and Looper now
the idea and we then brought it to
Colorado so this is something I believe
strongly in
um you know just as you know 80 percent
of the U.S prison population came from
Foster Care
we need to fix foster care it's a
massive problem and it's where a lot of
my Foundation efforts work but that said
so having gotten through two kids in
foster care with a lot of anger and you
know having been in 21 homes before in
our home
it was it was tumultuous and difficult
and you know it's it's uh it's one of
the best things I've ever done in my
life
um one of the boys is still very I
consider both of them my sons one of the
boys is still
um very close uh the other one is not
um
and I but I took a deep breath and I
said what am I going to do about kids
I mean my relationship with my father
was so important to me and you know I
wasn't ready to go back to the foster
care again
um I was single at the time and and I
started realizing what what came to me
was a young entrepreneur not not Jack
but another young entrepreneur named
jacobo he was working in my company
and he ended up uh needing a place to
stay and I had a big house empty nest
and I said why don't you stay there and
here's an extra car and we'll build this
company together and you know he and his
girlfriend lived there most of the time
but it became a very tight relationship
and he had had a struggled relationship
with his father and at some point along
the way he just started calling me pops
um that's beautiful and it was fantastic
and his daughter and his girlfriend at
the time was like a daughter-in-law and
it made me realize that family can be
very different so spin ahead to uh an
Ayahuasca Retreat I'm not sure if I need
to explain what that is to your your
viewers they can look it up if they
don't know yeah I was at a spiritual
retreat in Costa Rica
and um and I was I was helping I'm not a
shaman but I was hoping to organize the
peer-to-peer support and some of the the
work that's done around the medicine
that's that's delivered and um and and
there was this young man Jack
and during ceremony I was
um I was sitting there and I was
imagining myself and my old age and I
what I was visioning was myself as a
very old tree
and there were young Vines
around using that tree for sustenance
Etc
and ironically after the ceremony I was
about to share this this powerful story
and Jack shared the same story that had
envisioned to him
that he had found a mentor and and it
was a deep connection that we had had at
that spiritual Retreat
um and Jack became the second of my now
uh four boys the fourth of my now four
boys and subsequently I have two others
who like they and their their wives and
girlfriends they spend all of their
Christmases with us Etc and it's been
one of the greatest blessings of my life
to have formed and shaped a family that
might not look exactly like other people
think of as family
laughs
the forward tour is coming to a city
near you that means I'm coming to a city
near you I'm heading to San Francisco
Los Angeles Seattle Raleigh Denver and
more in the spring go to fordparty.com
to check out the upcoming dates or just
check out my social media primarily
Twitter unfortunately see you soon
[Music]
well Jack's a tremendous young man and
uh he's thrilled to have you uh as a
mentor uh and it speaks volumes about
the kind of person that you are
um so I was joking earlier about how a
lot of people eat alone more now or like
you know probably myself included uh how
do you feel about this new era of work
culture and I want to share a little bit
about my own journey in this so I've run
a couple of startups and uh non-profits
and I was very very into workplace
culture I considered myself uh like a
reasonable culture Setter but I I
thought that it was very important to be
together in one place to build
relationships to have this sort of trust
so now we're in this work from home era
and if you ask most employees what they
want to do they want to work from home a
lot of people who are heads of
organizations are on the other page
where they are saying look like we ought
to get back into the office
and and then there are communities that
are somewhere in between if you're in a
downtown Corridor you very much want
people back in the office you must have
organizations coming at you up to Wazoo
asking what the heck do we do with this
um what's your perspective both from the
individual worker
um and then to the CEO or the person
running an order well I am so excited to
ask me that question because this is the
core of research that my group has been
doing since 2010. so I was coaching
somebody named John Chambers and his
executive team at Cisco
um he was the CEO there and John
um had birthed WebEx telepresence all of
these virtual Communications in 2010
before anybody else had Eric Yoon by the
way was at Cisco at the time wow um the
chairman of Zoom what was interesting
was I I started asking the question this
virtual thing is going to be impactful
to business
and I approached Harvard Business School
press and I said I'd like to do a study
a five-year study of teams that are
remote first and hybrid this is in 2010.
and we did we published somewhere
12 to 15 pieces in Harvard Business
Review during that period of time and it
was called what are the new people rules
in a virtual world
so you could ask me any question I could
be able to give you some insight what
was interesting back then is nobody read
those pieces nobody cared nobody
believed in remote work and then in 2020
I raised five million dollars
um to do a new study which ultimately
ended up in this book competing in the
new world of work wow and we published
30 or 40 pieces around this inflection
point and what is now available to us in
remote and hybrid work so
let me give you
um some really interesting data that
will shock you a bit
please some of it won't
so let's take a look at different
categories of effective culture in teams
one of them is is relationships in
bonding connectedness that's not all of
culture there are other things in
culture like Candor and transparency
Innovation and ideation
accountability growth and development
collaboration so all we've been
measuring all of these categories for 20
years and the efficacy of teams I'm
gonna pick one bonding the average team
and their score on bonding together in
the in the pre-pandemic world
was 2.8 on a scale of zero to five
and that's answering questions like my
team has my back 2.8
or I deeply care about all members of my
team and all members of my team care
about me that word all really flips it
to being a lower score sure and there's
always that one jerk man
sorry and so that idea of 2.8 now what
happened was during the pandemic when
you were remote
you would imagine that that bonding
score would go down and it did it went
to 2.3 and here's why
because Andrew most CEOs think of
bonding
in a methodology I Call Serendipity
it's the walk down the hallway it's the
coffee room conversation right
but there were teams like Drew Houston
at Dropbox
that said now that we're in remote I
better learn how to do bonding
differently
and so he started engineering practices
that would accelerate the connectedness
of his team while remote so for instance
once a week that team would say to each
other
what is our energy level right now and
why
and so somebody would say oh it's a two
I'm really worried about my mom who's in
assisted living and it's locked down
during covid or whatever or you know I'm
a I'm a one my significant other got a
diagnosis or whatever or or I'm three
this project is draining me that we're
working on at work
now think about this for a second Andrew
in the olden days you might have had
those conversations
serendipitously in small pods yeah you
might have had the water cooler been
like oh I'm worried about my mom but
only in ones or twos
what if now you bring a full discussion
in the room where every week you have
that discussion what happens is the
entire empathy of the team goes up
so we curated five of these practices
that yield greater bonding
in a measurable way because we have the
data and if if a team adopted all five
practices the relational score went up
to 4.4 in a remote wow
that's better than it ever was in a
pre-pandemic world
so
the point is that I'll give you another
example really short one the average
meat talk about Candor transparency
having a full voice that's so important
inclusion the average team meeting of 12
people only have four people think
they're hurt
if you use
um a collaborative document before the
meeting
you know like a Google doc
and and you have people answering a
question before the meeting
then you come into the meeting everybody
having read each other's answers ready
to collaborate
on the basis of everybody's input
eight people feel that they've been
fully heard
that what's that that's like a doubling
that's double yeah yeah I mean and
that's asynchronous collaboration so
what people don't realize is we we
changed where we worked we had meetings
and we moved them to to zoom meetings or
or teams meetings
but what we missed was the opportunity
to actually have uh to work up and down
what we call the collaborative stack
what do what do you do in physical
meetings what do you do in remote
meetings and what do you do outside of
meetings in asynchronous collaboration
so this became a really important and
Powerful lesson that we needed to learn
about hybrid work which is you can have
greater candor
by leveraging the collaborative stack
and the tools more effectively you can
get more people involved you can have a
greater degree of inclusion you can have
like for instance instead of even having
12 people in the meeting you could have
30 people opining in this Google doc now
you've got greater inclusion more
diversity of input
and then when you get into the meeting
you land the plane with a smaller number
of people to rustle the ideas forward so
I I just want to make the suggestion to
anybody listening into CEOs that we're
we're a bit lazy and thinking the only
way to to breed
collaboration Innovation relationships
is old ways of working if you adopt new
ways of working with new tools you can
radically improve the ways we're working
so the the challenge I have for anybody
listening is don't try to make work as
good as it was prior to the pandemic
leverage hybrid work to make it better
than it ever was and it will include
physical work I'm not suggesting you
don't need it you need physical
collaboration for the relational things
for the emotional things for celebration
for fun for gritty issues you want to
wrestle to the ground and look people in
the eye that's where you use physical
collaboration so I hope this was
um you know illustrative a bit to some
deeper Curiosity on how hybrid work can
really make a difference
foreign
you guys already know all about
expressvpn I've talked before about why
they are the go-to service for
protecting your online activity big Tech
should not be snooping on us and
profiting from what we do in our private
time expressvpn can also help access
content including thousands of Netflix
shows that might be available in another
Market you just beam in encrypted
surreptitiously and you can be a UK user
and all of a sudden all that fun BBC
content can be yours I could go on and
on about expressvpn it's a VPN that I
trust and I'm not surprised that CNET
wired and others have rated at number
one visit expressvpn.com yang right now
and get three extra months of their
service for free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
well uh it makes perfect sense to me
that you need to engineer new practices
uh if you want
um a lot of the benefits of in-person
work
um because if you just like try and do
the in-person mode remotely it's going
to be a disaster in my opinion or I
guess by the number is that you know it
goes from 2.8 to 2.3 I actually think
that's pretty uh Rosy in the scheme of
things
um but it sounds like for you it's
maximize and optimize the tools for
remote work maximize and optimize the
tools for in-person work just try and
Max it out and and do things much more
consciously and deliberately yeah and
it'll be better than it ever was and I'm
I'm out there and I appreciate the
platform to ask me that question you
know
when I grew up in the 70s in Pittsburgh
the steel industry crashed
because the steel industry failed to
adopt new work practices that the
Japanese did adopt
the Japanese adopted tqm and Six Sigma
before the American steel industry and
kicked our ass
and as a result of that
um you know it was an entire city was
crushed Cleveland Pittsburgh Detroit
crushed
and and I grew up in poverty
recognizing that
it was poor management and the lack of
adoption wow of new ways of working
that had our our family suffer the way
it was and so that was my mission I I
had at the time I said I'm going to grow
up I'm going to be governor of
Pennsylvania I'm going to fix
manufacturing people will have jobs well
when I moved away from that mission and
I moved into a different mission of I'm
going to do that through business
and through the work that I've been
doing at frazzi Greenlight you know I
still have been able to accomplish that
it's true man like the the value
creation slash value destruction gap
between good management and bad
management is so epic you know I I
remember when I was in my 20s realizing
that if you just put some in as
CEO he could like record entire
organization I was like what you know
like that company just went down the
tubes because that like they brought in
this one person like you know that that
struck me as uh wild at the time one of
the blessings that I think we're gonna
see around AI
is that that mediocre individual that
the tank shareholder value will now be
visible I believe that within five years
software will be able to show whether an
individual is Raising or lowering
shareholder value in a very short while
AI should be able to assume a lot of the
resource allocation decisions uh for a
company and certainly to your point it
could screen what the heck is going on a
company-wide relative to each other it's
true if they're public if they're
private it'd be harder well no but just
think about this even in my own little
organization and I have a small sales
force
if AI if we did Employee Engagement
surveys
um of everybody which we do
I would be able to see the heat map of
where one leader in sales
was either increasing or decreasing
Employee Engagement
I would also be able to note based on
software and the use of HubSpot and
salesforce.com and those kind of things
I'd be able to note the productivity of
individuals we take all of this insight
and I'd be able to see throughput of
leads that turned into sales and who
touched them along the way pretty soon
I'd know exactly who my best sales
people are and I know who was poor I
mean it's it's going to be exciting you
know to be able to give managers The
Leverage of that kind of insight
um around data of every associate and
you know not just for the sake of your
inner you're out
um but also for the sake of coaching
we're going to be able to have ai
constantly coaching you of where you
should spend your time today
um that that will be able to give a heat
map to dialing up Revenue dialing down
Revenue it's going to be so exciting
so from your Pittsburgh example you
Champion something called radical
adaptability that uh it is uh not just
you but you're one of I think the most
prominent proponents
um we recently went through this crisis
around Silicon Valley Bank
um and I'm sure you had many many
friends who are incredibly stressed out
uh calling you
um I did uh you know I mean I didn't
have any personal uh Capital but I have
lots of friends who who were potentially
watching a decade of work get washed
away like having their their life
savings get decimated I knew somebody
had three billion dollars in that bank
it was real it was such a gut check
um thank goodness that in my mind it got
resolved in the right way which was the
like the depositors I mean if you hadn't
backstopped the depositors then there
would have been a run on every bank
that's not the top three Banks uh there
would have been a crisis of confidence
in the entire our U.S financial system
by the way warranted because if you
can't count on something as basic as
like you know this major Bank being
solvent the next day then you know your
trust in a lot of things kind of
dissipates I realized that that was yet
another example of massive value
destruction because of poor management
uh you know like happily the poor
management didn't Cascade all the way up
to the you know Federal Reserve and
secretary treasury FDIC but it was
important it was poor risk management on
the part of some Bank Executives at svb
uh if there were and I will say that
like I believe that this is going to be
the first of many Ripple effects of uh
elevated interest rates that there are
all sorts of land mines on the balance
sheets of all sorts of Institutions
um
I'm not sure where my question is on
this one but anybody turn it into let me
turn it into a piece of advice for our
listeners for today and whether or not
you know you're an institution or
whether you're an individual there's two
words I want to put together and you've
used both of them co-elevation and
radical adaptability
I want all of us to live our lives
Guided by co-elevation and radical
adaptability
I'll use myself for instance during the
pandemic
um I like many other individuals
invested heavily in the tech sector I've
always been I've always been you know
Peter diamandis who we're going to see
next week is my best friend and you know
he certainly has influenced me a lot in
terms of the future of technology and
its impact in the world why wouldn't you
believe that these stocks were actually
worth what they claimed to be worth
right because the future of Tesla isn't
a car it's a battery and it's future
Technologies and of course we believe
this right so
the echo chamber that we could create
around ourselves
um could be very damaging but a diverse
co-elevating team I have a chief
operating officer who is basically the
co-founder of frazzi Greenlight with me
as the very first person that came on
board his name is Jim Hannan
um and he's one of the most conservative
um right down the middle kind of guys
you'd ever want to meet one of the most
um wonderfully ethical solid dudes you'd
ever want to meet
um and you know he was warning me at the
time about the index that I had in my
portfolio to Tech
and he was just saying he's like yeah
you know you're a little indexed in that
direction and the ability to have those
voices strong in your life that that
diverse portfolio that coaches about
being over indexed yeah exactly that's
that's really where I started doing the
research was when I wrote this book
who's got your back and I realized that
we are all more successful when we've
got a diverse set of powerful and candid
honest truthful voices in our life now
what's important is
that you constantly tap into those on
regular agile sprints so agile has
become the operating system for the
world whether we know it or not those
who are not agile and I'm not just using
it as a descriptor being to be agile I
mean an operating system where you don't
imagine uh five years out you're
thinking of things on a monthly
bi-weekly basis and asking yourself what
have I learned lately and you take in
those inputs and you adjust and pivot
like a good entrepreneur would
or any engineer running an agile
software development we need to adapt
this in our lives now where Silicon
Valley Bank missed it is I'm sure they
didn't have a diverse set of individuals
who are co-elevating in terms of their
voices strategically
and I don't know with what agile Sprints
they worked to question their strategies
but I have to believe that not just a
week ago but more than a month ago we
could have predicted where we were
heading with Silicon Valley Bank and the
right voices in the room
with real co-elevation which means butt
kicking Candor peer-to-peer
accountability not letting each other
off the hook not just you know inhaling
the same exhaust fumes if all of that
had been present and they had run their
board in a way that I run my executive
teams that I coach in these agile
operating system I think we might have
seen a different different outcome uh I
I believe you're right uh you know there
was certainly some groupthink in in that
risk management office where they were
like yeah sure let's go heavy into these
bonds and not hedge it and let's make
them long term I mean you know that
ended up being the Catalyst to this
crisis of confidence that hopefully uh
stays contained it doesn't tear through
the the U.S financial system Keith this
has been an absolute pleasure and
privilege uh sharing time with you I'm
sure everyone who's listening to this or
watching it feels the same if someone
wants to dig into that brain of yours
and that Spirit of yours uh because
you're a remarkable human as well as
thinker uh how can they keep up with you
aside from buying all your books which I
recommend
they all have a lot to add and the way
the way I recommend you go on Amazon and
just read the first paragraph of each of
them and whichever one speaks to you is
where to go
um but I would I would say LinkedIn is
probably the best format
um to stay engaged with me and you'll
you know I I use that as a platform for
my thought leadership and you can you
can DM me I'm not gonna check all the
DMS myself but I have somebody checking
them and screening them to see you know
who I end up talking to so
um yeah that's uh that's probably wait a
way to max out LinkedIn that that
platform does have an awful lot of
potential
um I I will tell you a quick story
before we leave oh no please yeah years
ago I was at the Renaissance weekend and
this was when I had just published Never
Eat Alone
and this young man was there talking
about creating uh
uh this this platform this system for
deepening relationships
and and I said you know I really
appreciate what you're trying to do but
no way you can build relationships
through technology
um I'm not an advocate you know and at
that point in time Reid just nod his
head and said well I'm gonna go build it
anyway I did miss an opportunity along
the way to invest in a pretty
significant company and I was absolutely
wrong in my expectation now I and
because of that Miss I've absolutely
embraced all the new tools and
Technologies along the way to deepen
those relationships but Reed Hoffman
built an amazing platform which
continues to to thrive and to grow so
he's doing doing a great job there I
love that story story because it
demonstrates uh humility learning uh and
building great relationships
such a pleasure and I'll see you out
west in just a few days I'm looking
forward to it Andrew take care